OK, I have video for you today.
That is truly like nothing I have ever seen
before.
Donald Trump was interviewed on Fox News and
he tried to explain the genesis of getting
a cognitive assessment and brag about the
results.
And I have to tell you, this interview performance
by Donald Trump only raises more questions
about his cognitive state.
You really have to hear this.
Now, remember, the context is Sunday during
an interview with Fox News's Chris Wallace.
The topic of Trump's cognitive tests and cognitive
state came up.
Chris Wallace pointed out, according to a
new poll, people are more confident in Joe
Biden's cognitive state than in Donald Trump's.
And Donald Trump really reacted very strangely.
He told Chris Wallace on Sunday that he would
that Joe Biden wouldn't do as well as Trump
did on a cognitive test.
When Wallace pointed out, you know, that test
is pretty easy, it was like identify a drawing
of an elephant.
Trump said, well, the last five questions
are really tough.
And Trump even said to Chris Wallace that
Wallace himself wouldn't do super well on
the test, which is I mean, it's just absolutely
insane.
So cut to yesterday.
Trump is interviewed by Fox News and we've
got to go through it piece by piece.
And you'll see this is really something else.
Let's just jump right in.
Trump starting out by saying he sought out
a cognitive test in order to prove his critics
wrong.
He immediately goes off the rails into these
tangents of free association, a sort of verbal
inkblot test.
So the last time I was at the hospital, probably
a year ago, a little less than a year ago,
I asked a doctor.
I said, is there some kind of a cognitive
test that I could take?
Because I've been hearing about it because
I want to shut these people up to fake news.
They make up stories that mean like, I'll
do an interview with you.
I didn't say you can't ask me about this.
You can't touch me.
Ask me anything.
I did one with Chris Wallace, who was nice
enough to say.
He said, I just want to tell the audience.
There was no question that top down.
OK.
And he's a tough cookie.
And it was a good interview.
I liked it.
I enjoyed it.
And it was good.
But I didn't say you can only ask this.
You can only we have to be sharp if you're
in the office of the presidency.
We have to be sure.
So they were saying all these different things.
I was going all over whichever stuck.
None of it stuck, fortunately.
But one of the reasons it didn't is that I
took a test.
I said to the doctor, who is Dr. Ronnie Jackson?
I said, is there some kind of a test and acuity
test?
And he said, there actually is.
And he named it whatever it might be.
Then it was thirty or thirty five questions.
The first questions are very easy.
The last questions are much more difficult.
Okay, so let's stop there.
Trump says he did this a year or less than
a year ago in January of 2018.
Was when we reported that Trump took the Montreal
cognitive assessment and claims to have scored
a perfect score on it.
So if Trump is referring to that test as being
less than a year ago, that's weird.
Did he take another test more recently?
We don't know.
But as far as we were told, Trump's last cognitive
test was two and a half years ago.
Trump says it was recent, like in less.
More recently than the last year.
That's another one of these questions.
Now, he also mentions he did it with Dr. Ronnie
Jackson, Dr. Ronnie Jackson, as far as IRA.
Paul was already gone in March or April of
2018, so it would be very weird for Trump
to be saying I took this less than a year
ago with Dr. Ronnie Jackson because Ronnie
Jackson was gone.
At that point in time, it's weird.
Trump also says that it's 30 or 35 questions.
Well, if it is the Montreal cognitive assessment,
it's out of 30 points.
It's certainly not 30 questions, depending
on what you consider a question.
It's sort of like 15 different exercises.
Again, the last ones are not difficult, but
let's continue, because then Trump gets into
that.
And this is maybe the most interesting part,
like a memory question.
It's like he'll go person, woman, man, camera,
TV show.
They say, could you repeat that?
So I said, Yeah.
So it's person, woman, man, camera, TV David
Pakman.
Now, this is absolutely fascinating.
Trump gives examples of the memory part.
He says, you know, you have to remember five
words, person, woman, man, camera, TV.
Now, what Trump is doing there is he's grouping
or chunking the terms by theme.
And he's clearly just looking around.
And, you know, he was talking to a man.
There must have been a woman, you know, maybe
off camera, he says, camera TV.
That actually raises more questions about
Trump's cognitive state, because the way this
would normally be done is with unrelated terms.
The examples in the sample tests that we have
and are showing our audience the example words
are Face Velvet Church, Daisy Red.
So, again, the words are not related.
And the fact that Trump found that question
difficult and maybe he even got an easier
version.
Right.
Like in other words, if Trump's five words
that he was given were related.
That is also very strange that he would find
it difficult.
So Trump is just picking things around him
that makes it a way easier question.
And again, it shouldn't be particularly tough.
Let's continue.
OK.
That's very good.
If you get it in order, you get extra points.
If you.
OK.
Now he's asking you other questions.
Other questions.
And then 10 minutes, 15, 20 minutes later.
The first question, not the first, but the
tenth question.
Give us that again.
Can you do that again?
And you go person, woman, man, camera, TV.
If you get it in order, you get extra points.
They should.
Nobody gets it in order.
It's actually not that easy.
But for me, it was easy.
So here it truly sounds like Trump is being
treated like a difficult child.
What a good boy.
You got the words.
Not only did you get the words right, Donny,
you got them in order.
Here's a lolly and a sticker to put on your
shirt.
No one gets them in order.
Trump says, does does anybody understand how
insane it is that Trump is bragging about
this and he actually keeps going?
And that's not an easy question.
In other words, they ask you, do they give
you five names and you have to repeat them?
And that's OK.
If you repeat them out of order, that's OK.
But but, you know, it's not as good.
But then when you go back about 20, 25 minutes
later and they should go back to that quote
did I'll tell you this.
Now, the interviewer, despite not really questioning
what Trump is saying, visibly looks shell
shocked by what Donald Trump is talking about.
But I'm not giving the guy credit.
He could have challenged any single one of
these assertions and he didn't.
And then Trump portrays passing the test as
if he just, you know, splice the atom or something.
It's stunning.
You know, if you take this test, we may have
to reveal that you should have been.
Is it tough?
Tell me about.
Never heard of it.
And I got a perfect mark.
And the doctors were they said very few people
can do that.
Very few people get that.
You understand?
It's not that easy.
Your other question is tougher than what I
just did.
Now, there Trump says that there were even
harder questions than remembering five words.
There really aren't.
I mean, what there's this question where as
an example, you start with 100 and then they
tell you count backwards by seven from 100
to go.
OK, 193, 86, 79, 72, etc..
Maybe that's what Trump is referring to.
There's another one which is like name as
many words as you can in a minute.
Let's start with the letter D. And you've
got to go, you know, dog, doofus deprave,
dilapidated.
You know, it's that you get it.
So there really aren't more difficult questions.
And that's also weird that Trump is bringing
up.
And then just one more clip here.
But it's not that easy.
But as soon as they announced my score and
their test, all the stuff went away about
me.
Is he competent?
Remember they talking about 25th Amendment
nonsense?
And they said, wow.
And even the enemies, they don't say that
anymore.
But they do say it about Joe Biden.
And honestly, he should take the test in a
way as an obligation to.
Because you have to be able to.
Show this country that the person that we're
picking as leader is sharp.
Now, of course, the concerns didn't go away
when Trump took the test.
In fact, taking that test has raised even
more questions, and Trump's commentary on
the test has raised even more questions.
This is one of the strangest overall timelines
that we've been in for American polychaete
politics, certainly since I've had The David
Pakman Show, certainly since I've been following
politics and even really that I can remember
while I was alive that this is outrageous.
It's outrageous what's going on in.
Another strange thing is that Trump now says
the reason he sought out the test was to disprove
claims of cognitive decline.
He never said that at the time.
It's another inconsistency, but it also tells
us Trump clearly is following these narratives
that are appearing primarily on independent
media.
And I know we've joked around before about
indications that he either Don Junior or Donald
Trump, may have seen segments of the David
Pakman show.
I'm not claiming that that's the case.
And I know it's certainly conceivable.
But but I have no idea, although I am aware
of some aides at the White House that are
certainly aware of the show.
But what's clear is even when these things
don't appear on corporate media and we say,
you know, corporate media really should be
talking about X, Y or Z, the cognitive stuff
has only appeared on corporate media in the
last couple of months, years ago.
Independent media was talking about it and
it is very clear that Donald Trump was aware
of it.
And that also is interesting.
It's not just Fox News that is sort of informing
Donald Trump's understanding.
And lastly, Trump still keeps talking about
these cognitive tests as if they're kind of
like IQ type memory games rather than just
crude screenings for dementia.
Everything about it is outrageous.
And we'll have probably a poll question about
this on our Instagram page.
So make sure you are following us there at
David Pakman show on Instagram.
And if you happen to pull up your Instagram
app on your phone, you might as well give
me a follow.
You can check out my urban backyard garden
and a lot of other wacky things.